[Música]
desde hace varios días lo hemos venido
aquí reportando en France 24 cientos de
migrantes indocumentados que decidieron
dejar el territorio chileno muchos de
ellos venezolanos haitianos y
colombianos están frenados en su
travesía en la llamada línea de
Concordia que es uno de los pasos
fronterizos entre chile y Perú los
migrantes no pueden ingresar de manera
regular a este país debido a las
militarizaciones que han tenido lugar en
la frontera de Perú por parte del
gobierno de ese país que se suman
también a un endurecimiento de las
medidas migratorias en Chile muchos de
ellos han tenido que soportar hambre
también frío porque recordemos que en el
hemisferio sur el otoño está por
terminar y el invierno ya está a la
vuelta de la esquina mi compañera Rosa
Pérez mateu en el programa directo
América adiciona matutina conversó con
Gerardo espíndola el alcalde de la
ciudad de arica en la frontera chileno
peruana y nos contó lo que le pide al
gobierno central Santiago para hacer
frente a esta situación escuchemos Qué
piden ustedes a las autoridades
nacionales tanto de chile como de Perú
que hagan para resolver esta situación
bueno nosotros como municipalidad Somos
la municipalidad que está afectada
finalmente por esta situación hemos
estado pidiendo ya yo estuve en la
cancillería de chile la semana pasada y
estamos en realidad con este diálogo más
o menos desde el mes de noviembre cuando
empezamos a detectar esta situación lo
hablamos con el Ministerio del interior
y de ahí está surgiendo la idea de hacer
un corredor humanitario terrestre aéreo
como sea y en el caso de que fueron
corredor humanitario terrestre que
permita descomprimir lo que está pasando
en las fronteras es que tanto chile Perú
Ecuador Colombia y Venezuela se pongan
de acuerdo para el para el traslado
terrestre de personas hasta Venezuela
siendo Perú Ecuador y Colombia solamente
países de tránsito y no países de
destino y para eso hay que establecer
una buena coordinación
entre los migrantes también ha habido
tensión esto provocó enfrentamientos
incluso algunos se lanzaron piedras y
otros bloquearon algunas de las rutas
del lado chileno mientras que las
autoridades consulares de Venezuela
llegaron hasta la zona para hacer un
censo de sus connacionales y poderles
dar asistencia recientemente el
canciller de chile Alberto van clever en
informó que Venezuela ya programó un
vuelo en el que podrán viajar los
ciudadanos de este país que están tanto
en la ciudad de arica que es en el lado
chileno como en la ciudad de tacna que
está del otro lado de la frontera en
territorio peruano hoy en el debate de
France 24 analizamos Entonces cómo está
la situación en la frontera peruano
chilena y esta situación migratoria en
nuestra región en la región de América
Latina para conversar sobre este tema
hemos invitado a Nancy Arellano ella es
presidenta fundadora de la ong ven
activa ella se encuentra en la Ciudad de
Lima en Perú y en la ciudad de Santiago
en chile se conecta Rodrigo Bustos ls
director ejecutivo de amnistía
internacional en Chile también es
defensor de los Derechos Humanos
recuerden ustedes nuestros televidentes
que también hacen parte de este debate
pueden dejar comentarios preguntas
a través de las redes sociales ya lo
saben estamos en Twitter también nos
encuentran en Facebook y también en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral el debate f24
todo junto y a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como arroba santilogo les
recuerdo también que todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
pues vamos directo Entonces al análisis
saludo a Nancy en la Ciudad de Lima la
capital peruana Nancy Gracias por estar
con nosotros y bueno su análisis de lo
que está sucediendo en esta frontera una
frontera que siempre ha sido un punto
como dicen caliente en esta ruta
migratoria en el Continente
latinoamericano en la región de América
Latina y está creciente
tensión digámoslo así diplomática entre
chile y Perú a raíz de este de lo que
está sucediendo en este punto fronterizo
Sí en efecto es una muestra de la de la
necesidad de coordinar en este momento
la movilidad humana en la región
recordemos que en el caso de la crisis
venezolana se creó el proceso de Quito
que en este momento de hecho chile tiene
la presidencia protempore y es
importante entender que la toma de
medidas en cada uno de los países afecta
los flujos migratorios en toda la región
estamos ante la situación además de
imposibilidad de un número
importantísimo de migrantes y poder
conseguir documentación que garantice o
que les identifique sobre todo aquellos
que iniciaron la movilidad regional con
cédula de identidad
que es un documento que no se emite
fuera de la fronteras venezolanas y que
es un documento que fue hábil para
viajar o para ingresar a varios de estos
países cuando todavía se mantenía el
reconocimiento de Venezuela
como parte del mercosur cuando no se
había dado la suspensión de Venezuela en
el mercosur Y entonces creemos que es
una situación que puede complejizarse en
números en paso fronterizos y que puede
resultar absolutamente perniciosa para
el caso de garantizar Insisto que estas
personas no terminen Víctimas de de
trata de personas que sabemos que hay
cifras bastante alarmantes en el
crecimiento específico de este delito
francy gracias por este panorama que nos
da usted su opinión sobre este tema
vamos a preguntarle a Rodrigo en la
ciudad de Santiago también su impresión
su perspectiva de lo que significa esta
atención diplomática entre chile y Perú
y la situación de lo que se está
viviendo particularmente del lado
chileno
Bueno la verdad es que se trata de una
situación que muy preocupante hemos
observado durante días estas imágenes
donde hay cientos de personas que se
encuentran
de una manera muy muy precaria
hay niños niñas hay mujeres embarazada y
persona adulta mayores
que están muy muy vulnerables y donde no
ha habido hasta el momento una solución
definitiva respecto de esta persona que
señalan querer regresar en su gran
mayoría
a Venezuela o a otros países y y por lo
tanto importante ese diálogo yo diría
por parte de las autoridades de chile y
de Perú pero más allá de El abordaje de
esta situación puntual en la frontera
entre chile y Perú se requiere un
abordaje multilateral entre los
gobiernos de los diversos estados de
América del Sur frente a desde omnistía
internacional llamamos más que una
crisis migratoria una crisis de personas
refugiadas porque cuando hablamos de las
personas venezolanas que se han estado
desplazando en los últimos diez años y y
importante recordar que se trata del
segundo desplazamiento Éxodo más grande
de la historia contemporánea después del
de Ucrania y ya superando El Éxodo de
personas sirias lo que hay son personas
que requieren protección internacional
respecto de una situación de violencia
generalizada y de violaciones a los
Derechos Humanos que existen Venezuela
por lo tanto debiera haber ese abordaje
multilateral para poder brindar
protección a las personas venezolanas
que han estado saliendo del territorio
de dicho país
viendo ya teniendo claro el panorama y
la opinión de nuestros invitados paso a
preguntarle a Nancy comienzo por
analizar la situación que está viviendo
Perú en este momento Nancy allí ha sido
muy controvertido en las últimas semanas
esa decisión de la presidenta Dina
boluarte de declarar el estado de
emergencia y militarizar las fronteras
aduciendo que a través de un control
mayor de las personas que entran al país
pueden empezar a ver una reducción de la
violencia argumentando que el incremento
de la violencia ha sido por la llegada
de migrantes y en buena parte de ellos
procedentes de Venezuela sin presentar
ninguna cifra ningún tipo de prueba
sobre ellos simplemente dando este
argumento su opinión sobre esta
estigmatización de los venezolanos esta
estigmatización de los migrantes y que
tan productiva puede ser para Perú de
verdad Esta medida Esto sí va a
garantizar una mejora de la seguridad o
esto tiene un trasfondo político
Bueno ahí creemos que es importante
ver las dos caras no por un lado como en
efecto señalas no existe base
estadística que permita demostrar que
hay una correlación en el momento de la
criminalidad y la de la llegada de los
extranjeros a territorio segundo
paralelamente se aprobó la amnistía eh
migratoria que también es cierto y se
habilitaron unos cambios normativos para
propiciar la regularización de las
personas que ya están dentro del
territorio recordemos que en el caso del
Perú tenemos casi ochocientas mil
personas que se encuentran en situación
Regular o en situación de de regularidad
precaria por decirlo así tenemos
quinientos mil solicitantes de refugio y
tenemos un reto de casi cuatrocientos
mil que deben ser regularizados entonces
hay medidas que están propendiendo a
facilitar la regularización dentro del
territorio
y para lelamente Se tomaron estas
medidas respecto de la frontera y además
en efecto ha habido unos discursos
perdón criminalizantes
que se basan en casos muy específicos
muy específicos que nos resultan
representativos no resultan en una
muestra representativa eso no quita que
que se empatice con el dolor de las
personas que han sido víctimas y sus
familiares pero no se puede generalizar
por nacionalidad porque de hecho hemos
cotejado la cifras estadísticas por cien
por cada cien habitantes así como la
comparativa Por ejemplo si Venezuela los
venezolanos en el Perú fuesen un un
departamento serían el cuarto
departamento más grande del país
equivalente al departamento de Arequipa
y las cifras de criminalidad de nuestro
departamento imaginario
estarían muy por debajo de departamentos
con tamaños similar y muy por debajo
específicamente de de la del país de la
media Nacional de hecho empuja la tasa
veinte por ciento por debajo a nivel
nacional Sí y pasó al otro lado de la
frontera Rodrigo también en Chile han
tomado algunas medidas recientes para
endurecer los procesos migratorios es
parte de estas políticas que está
adelantando el presidente burich borich
su perspectiva sobre lo que significa el
cambio de esta política y el manejo que
se le está dando a los grupos
migratorios en este momento muchos de
ellos después de estar de forma
irregular en Chile pues han optado por
irse del país ante el cambio de las de
las leyes y también por la falta Pues de
poder establecerse allí para para tener
una vida un poco más estable
Sí la verdad es que
en Chile en este momento está pendiente
la dictación de una política migratoria
de acuerdo a la nueva ley que entró en
vigencia hace poco más de un año y le
debiera tener una política migratoria y
se debieran establecer entonces
mecanismos para regularizar a las
personas que se encuentran en condición
de irregularidad se debieran también
establecer visas de oportunidad laboral
pero también de acuerdo a los fines de
esa política migratoria que a más de un
año de entrada en vigencia la nueva ley
migratoria todavía no se dicta Entonces
tenemos esta situación que no permite
avanzar en tener una migración ordenada
regular que pueda contribuir
adecuadamente al desarrollo del país al
progreso de chile y por otra parte
también en Chile tenemos
fenómenos similar al que comentaba Nancy
en Perú
El Avance de discursos criminalizadores
de la migración con varios proyectos de
ley incluso que pretende establecer
pretende establecer una asociación
prácticamente automática entre la
migración irregular y la delincuencia
Estableciendo como delito la migración
irregular o el ingreso clandestino tanto
amnistía internacional como la oficina
del alto comisionado de Naciones Unidas
como acnur hemos rechazado ese proyecto
de ley que hoy día se está discutiendo
en el congreso Porque por cierto iría en
contra de la obligación internacionales
que el estado chileno ha suscrito de no
criminalizar la migración y de tener
políticas migratorias que En definitiva
signifiquen un derecho lo respetar los
derechos de las personas migrantes en
nuestro país Rodrigo continuó con usted
para hacer la ronda en sentido contrario
la migración en América latina no es
algo nuevo hemos tenido diferentes
episodios preocupantes a lo largo de la
historia y lo que sucede con los
venezolanos en este momento y los
haitianos y también los colombianos pues
es uno de esos capítulos de repunte de
de migrantes que se mueven a lo largo de
ancho del continente Buscando una mejor
calidad de vida y también escapando de
la violencia y la falta de oportunidades
porque América Latina no tiene un marco
migratorio un poco más robusto sobre
todo estos países que han sido
receptores de migrantes como es el caso
de chile que ha recibido a lo largo de
los años muchas personas procedentes de
Bolivia incluso de la vecina Argentina
Haití en otro momento de Venezuela Por
qué no hay un marco cuando Esto es algo
que ha venido a lo largo de los años no
es algo nuevo
Bueno la verdad que
en cierta medida hay un marco
chile ha suscrito tratado
internacionales de Derechos Humanos
referente a los derechos de las personas
migrantes también respecto a Refugio
chile es parte de la convención de 1951
de Naciones Unidas de la convención o de
la declaración de Cartagena de 1984
tiene una ley en materia de Refugio del
año 2010 que es muy acorde a esa
obligación internacionales pero lo que
ocurre es que por ejemplo cuando
hablamos de Refugio la normativa
Simplemente no se cumple por parte de la
autoridad administrativa incluso hay
diversos fallos de los tribunales
Superiores de Justicia que han señalado
aquello que han instado a la autoridad
administrativa a cumplir con la ley de
Refugio a tener nuevos protocolos para
que la persona puedan solicitar asilo si
es que así lo requieren especialmente
las personas venezolanas da la crisis de
Derechos Humanos que hay en ese país
entonces
en el ámbito Refugio al menos hay una
normativa y Simplemente no se aplica en
el caso de todo lo referido a los flujos
migratorios en general hay una nueva
legislación que establece la necesidad
la existencia de una política migratoria
pero en ese caso lo que sucede es que el
gobierno actual está al debe no ha
cumplido contener esa política
migratoria que permitiría poder tener
mecanismos para regularizar a las
personas que no están en situación de
regularidad establecer visas de
oportunidad laboral Entonces yo diría
que más que el problema de falta de
Marcos normativos regulatorios el
problema es la existencia de prácticas
hoy en día que se alejan de la norma
internacionales en materia de refugio y
migración Nancy y le su opinión sobre
este tema Cuál es su opinión bueno
coincide con lo que dice Rodrigo hay un
marco legal pero no una puesta en marcha
ni aplicación de forma por parte de las
autoridades de forma óptica óptima
Perdón óptima Mira Sí en el caso como te
digo Hay un montón de acuerdos
establecidos en en la región y
mecanismos que no se están utilizando eh
correctamente para articular las medidas
correspondientes Pero además hay un tema
en la adecuación de las normativas
internas para garantizar procesos de
integración y evitar procesos de
remigración irregular por un lado por
otro lado también es cierto que pasar
del enfoque de securitización al enfoque
de derechos en países que históricamente
no han tenido inmigraciones masivas en
las recientes décadas es todo un para el
manejo de los espacios discrecionales
por parte de las autoridades
administrativas ahí creemos que sigue
existiendo el reto de sensibilizar a las
autoridades y que se comprenda que las
decisiones que se toman en los
escenarios internacionales deben ser eh
consustanciadas con las prácticas y con
los procederes y el uso del espacio
discrecional Por quienes son la cara del
Estado frente a los extranjeros en
territorio creemos que allí todavía hay
mucho por hacer en el caso de Perú
Tampoco puede desconocerse y habilitado
una serie de mecanismos de
regularización continuamente desde el
ptp el cpp cero diez nuevamente ahora se
está aplicando el tema de la amnistía
tiene admitido los quinientos treinta y
siete mil solicitantes de Refugio pero
no se ha logrado por ejemplo establecer
una ruta Clara hacia la formalización y
establecer rutas que permitan destrabar
el potencial que bien ha señalado el
fondo monetario internacional puede
tener la migración en territorio que
puede alcanzar el caso de chile Dos
punto cinco puntos del pbi en el caso
del Perú cuatro punto cinco puntos del
pbi y creo que Esa visión de cómo la
migración puede agregar valor eh No es
el discurso que está dominando los
medios sino más bien el enfoque del
miedo basado en la casuística
excepcional y que termina alimentando el
enfoque de seguridad contrario el
enfoque de integración que sería más
productivo para todos y es usado como un
comodín político en campañas y para
simplemente pues ganar algunos sectores
de las sociedades ustedes mencionaron en
algunas de sus intervenciones
esa necesidad de crear una especie de
Alianza o de coordinación a nivel
internacional con los diferentes países
de la región de América Latina desde
México hasta chile y Argentina para
ponerle un poco de a esto porque
finalmente de una u otra forma o como un
actor o como el otro pero prácticamente
todos los países de la región están
involucrados en este proceso por qué no
ha habido una coordinación entre los
países que cada uno cumpla un rol siendo
un país de tránsito o un país de refugio
para tener una espera mientras saltan al
país hacia el que se van a aproximar o
el país que los va a recibir América
Latina le ha costado mucho hacer un
engranaje incluso con Estados Unidos que
es un país que es un gran receptor de
los migrantes latinoamericanos ahora la
nueva política del presidente biden ha
destinado que Guatemala y Colombia pasan
a ser unos países Refugio pero aquí
entonces cómo se van a coordinar quién
puede organizar esto quién puede liderar
esto México que es el país donde están
llegando la gran mayoría a representarse
en la frontera o chile que está teniendo
esta problemática en este momento o Perú
que tiene ahora un estado de emergencia
Rodrigo cómo lo ve usted
o sea creo comparto plenamente lo que
decía también Nancy anteriormente en el
sentido de que hay diversos estudios que
demuestran que la migración puede
claramente ser una oportunidad para el
progreso de los países
hay hay diversos estudios en esa materia
en chile se viene señalando por parte de
diversas asociaciones de empresarios de
que hay un déficit por ejemplo de mano
obra en varias áreas en el ámbito de la
construcción de la de la minería y en
otros ámbitos y por lo tanto La verdad
es que debiera avanzarse en la
perspectiva de entender que la persona
migrante pueden contribuir al desarrollo
del país y y en cambio en varios de
nuestro país en Perú en Chile lo que hay
es como bien señalaban así también ha
ocurrido en Chile a partir de casos
específicos pero no
considerando la estadística globales en
relación a la delincuencia a partir de
esos casos específicos se generan
estereotipos se establecen discursos
criminalizadores y no sé permite digamos
que la migración pueda contribuir al
desarrollo de los países sobre tu
pregunta cómo quién debiera liderar esto
la verdad es que hoy día Lamentablemente
vemos gobiernos que básicamente se suman
a estos discursos criminalizadores y
finalmente eso no contribuye Por cierto
a tener una un acuerdo un diálogo
multilateral que nos permita cambiar de
paradigma y pasaron paradigmas donde la
migración tiene otro rol al desarrollo
de los países y donde finalmente este
orden que se requiere se establece en
conjunto por parte de los gobiernos de
los distintos estados
y Nancy su su opinión este sistema
continental de migración porque no tiene
ningún tipo de funcionamiento
hay instancias más allá del proceso de
Quito está la red iberoamericana de
autoridades migratorias está el consejo
sudamericano de migraciones
recientemente estuvo la conferencia de
solidaridad para migrantes venezolanos
que fue en Bruselas eh la conferencia de
donantes allí estuvo liderando la Unión
Europea y Canadá por ejemplo las rondas
de de donantes donde los países
receptores de migrantes establecieron
Por ejemplo cuáles eran sus necesidades
presiones etcétera y yo creo que hay que
aterrizar esto
ese tipo de espacios en medidas
concretas y en acuerdos eh Porque
Lamentablemente muchos de Estos espacios
se han vuelto simplemente espacios Donde
ha habido unas unos discursos sobre las
medidas que están tomando pero no hay
acuerdos o no hay concertación en Cómo
se pueden manejar los flujos en la
región no es menos cierto además de que
la mayoría de los acuerdos de movilidad
humana
gozan en acuerdos de carácter económico
y político como es el caso del mercosur
como es el caso de Alianza Pacífico como
es el caso de la comunidad andina que
son los mecanismos donde hoy día no
tiene presencia por ejemplo Venezuela
Entonces es como Cómo abordamos el tema
seriamente si tenemos todo un entramado
de instancias pero por ejemplo en donde
hay Los acuerdos más prácticos no
participa el país que es el mayor emisor
de migrantes o no sé o no se considera
Qué hacer cuando el país que es el mayor
emisor de migrantes no forma parte de
estos acuerdos entonces ahí yo creo que
hay que hacer bien bien pragmáticos en
el sentido de la preminencia de los
derechos humanos y por supuesto
comprender que hay tiene que haber base
en evidencia para la concertación de
políticas que realmente protejan a los
ciudadanos y protegen a todas las
personas del territorio y más bien
eviten que el crimen organizado
transnacional termine volviéndose
para el tráfico de migrantes para la
trata de personas para actividades
delincuenciales justamente porque el
estado se retrae de su deber justamente
de generar paso seguros y de proteger a
las personas claro importante ese punto
Nancy y yo hacía esta pregunta porque
recuerdo muy bien Que en la Cumbre de
las Américas que tuvo lugar en la ciudad
de Los Ángeles uno de los puntos
acordados era darle una prioridad al
tema migratorio y desarrollar este
digamos sistema un un una alianza o
mayor cooperación a nivel del continente
para
poder hacer frente a esta crítica
situación de los migrantes en la región
de América Latina vamos a arrepentirnos
ahora al caso puntual de la frontera
entre chile y Perú veíamos las palabras
del alcalde de la ciudad de arica que
hablaba de la creación de un corredor
humanitario un corredor terrestre en el
mejor de los casos para poder destrabar
lo que está pasando allí y pero pues eso
es simplemente se quedó en una especie
de Propuesta eso no no se ha podido
llevar a cabo por ahora solamente llegar
a ese vuelo procedente de Venezuela el
domingo para llevarse a los ciudadanos
venezolanos desde arica y tacna hasta
Venezuela Cómo empezar entonces a
establecer ese corredor Rodrigo aquí
Cómo se distribuyen las cargas
la verdad es que entendemos que son
varias las alternativas que se han
estado barajando en los últimos días Una
de ellas es exactamente un corredor
humanitario es bueno que quienes nos
escuchan puedan tener claro que un
corredor humanitario una situación es un
camino bien excepcional que se ha
estableció pocas veces o algunas veces
los últimos 30 años en crisis como la de
Siria en el contexto también de la
invasión de Rusia a Ucrania y que se
establece por un periodo bien específico
de tiempo respecto de una franja del
territorio para que en este caso por lo
menos las personas venezolanas pudieran
eventualmente regresar a Venezuela pero
requiere efectivamente esta coordinación
logística entre varios estados y
gobiernos
otra alternativa que al parecer se ha
barajaban los últimos días que ha estado
arriba la mesa es la posibilidad de
algún vuelo
pareciera ser que finalmente lo más
probable
donde el estado de Venezuela pondría
aviones para que la persona puedan
regresar a Caracas en en buena medida la
mayoría al menos de estas trescientas
aproximadamente trescientas personas que
están en esa zona limítrofe Yo te diría
eso sí que que es importante Por una
parte que esto se realice Con urgencia
porque la verdad es que las personas que
se encuentran en esa zona están ya hace
muchos días en condiciones muy precarias
Hay personas que son muy vulnerables
como decía anteriormente mujer
embarazada persona adultas mayores niño
y niñas y por otra parte lo que hablamos
anteriormente que hayan un abordaje más
sostenible duradero tanto respecto
internamente de cada uno de los países
con una perspectiva
basada en los derechos humanos en sus
políticas migratorias y de refugio y por
otra parte con un diálogo multilateral
en base a varios acuerdos como
mencionaba Nancy que están vigentes y
que permitiría justamente poder ordenar
de mejor medida mejor manera los flujos
migratorios que han estado sucediendo en
los últimos años en nuestros países
Nancy su opinión en la Ciudad de Lima
Cómo establecer este corredor cuando
Perú tiene las fronteras militarizadas
bueno justamente en la experiencia más
reciente ha sido la pandemia no durante
la pandemia aún estaba emergencia
llamó a establecer corredores aéreos
humanitarios y hubo permisos especiales
para eh cumplir con el deber de
protección consular de las personas creo
que aquí insisto El Deber de protección
consular está vigente está llamado a
cumplir el rol de protección en materia
de identidad y sobre todo en el caso de
personas que tienen voluntad de volver a
sus países de origen y segundo estamos
hablando de que hay que buscar la forma
de que haya acción sin daño es muy
importante en la intervención de todos
los organismos internacionales de la
perspectiva de acción sin daño sea
recurrente sea una constante y Esto va
incluso para la comprensión de las
propias medidas que tomen los propios
estados porque insisto favorecer los
discursos de securitización pueden
terminar más bien por generar más alarma
rechazo eh procesos discriminatorios
tensión social y trayendo consigo
movimientos absolutamente no
planificados movimientos nerviosos por
parte de las comunidades de extranjeros
en territorio que terminan generando
este tipo de conflictos fronterizos
allí la responsabilidad de las
autoridades es proteger insisto no
solamente las que tienen la
responsabilidad fronteriza sino también
de los estados de origen de cada uno de
estos Y por supuesto El Deber de cada
uno de estos estados de notificar a los
consulados la presencia de Nacionales de
sus países en la fronteras allí
entendemos que por ejemplo en el caso
del consulado colombiano no había sido
notificado de Cuántos ciudadanos
colombianos estaban presentes en
territorio eh eso es
resaltarlo allí porque justamente de eso
se trata de que haya las coordinaciones
entre los países para que se puedan cada
cada uno pueda aportar desde la
perspectiva que le corresponde e insisto
siempre y cuando haya voluntad de
retorno de sus nacionales y no hay un
temor fundado de persecución del estado
de origen donde en efecto debe activarse
los mecanismos de Refugio porque uno ve
de acuerdo a esta explicación que usted
hace Nancy es que hay muchas fallas en
esta cadena muchos partes del engranaje
que no responden en el momento que deben
de responder eso también colabora a que
la crisis se incremente y se agudice con
el paso de los días esta crisis de la
frontera entre chile y Perú Lleva más de
20 días y pues se queda uno pensando
como el consulado colombiano en Santiago
o en Lima no ha hecho una acción rápida
teniendo en cuenta que buena parte de
los que están allí esperando para cruzar
a territorio peruano son de nacionalidad
colombiana queda uno pensando pues en la
cadena Pues empieza a entorpecer ese
proceso para ayudar a desbloquear la
frontera Más allá de las discrepancias
diplomáticas que puedan tener los países
es un deber de los países funcionar sin
Nancy hecho el consulado colombiano
tuvo a bien darnos el correo electrónico
del consulado para que buscásemos
compartirlo con con las personas que
estaban yendo a terreno Y es C de casa
sede consulado Lima arroba cancillería
punto gob punto ceo para las personas
que sepan de alguien que está allí que
pueden notificar a su consulado en el
caso de los colombianos Bueno pues
hacemos ese ese servicio para que la
gente que que necesite tener acceso a al
servicio que pueda dar el consulado allí
en en chile o en Perú pues bueno en este
caso de Perú Pues el consulado en Lima
puedan obtener la atención me quedan ya
pocos minutos para finalizar el programa
como vieron lo abordamos digo yo en dos
alturas este caso de la frontera entre
chile y Perú pero también aproveché para
hacer una especie de vista rápida Cómo
está la situación en América Latina del
tema migratorio comienzo Entonces Con
Rodrigo su conclusión lo que viene para
esta crisis puntual en la frontera que
va a pasar en los próximos días cómo se
va a destrabar esto y a nivel del
continente cómo empezar a dar pasos para
esa esa ese organismo que pueda engranar
y generar una cadena a nivel continental
o por donde usted quiera enfocar su
conclusión
sí lo lo importante que efectivamente
haya una salida rápida porque como bien
tú has señalado ya estas personas llevan
varias semanas en condiciones muy
inhumanas en la zona fronteriza y y por
lo tanto sea que se trate un corredor
humanitario ya más probablemente de
algún traslado en avión a Venezuela o a
Colombia
Esperamos que eso pueda efectivamente
suceder pronto ahora bien como te decía
anteriormente aquí se requiere que
efectivamente las autoridades de los
diversos gobiernos se sienten puedan
dialogar respecto de soluciones de
acuerdo más duraderos en relación a la
crisis migratoria
particularmente en relación a la persona
que se han desplazado de Venezuela como
te señalaba hace un rato atrás ya son
siete millones
siete millones doscientas mil personas
de Venezuela que han salido de su
fronteras en los últimos diez años más
de seis millones están en América Latina
y el Caribe y ese tipo de crisis no
puede abordarse de manera urinateral por
parte de todos los gobiernos tiene que
haber una respuesta
conjunta por parte de los estados cosa
que no ha ocurrido hasta ahora pero que
es absolutamente imprescindible y
urgente una acción en bloque en conjunto
para dar atención a la migración
venezolana Nancy su conclusión para el
cierre del programa
Bueno creo que muy de acuerdo con con lo
que han comentado segundo no perder de
vista los flujos migratorios no
solamente no Sur Norte entendiendo que
ha habido un repunte de salidas por
parte de algunos países y que eso está
fortaleciendo eh graves transgresiones a
los derechos humanos en América Central
por eso hemos visto las medidas que que
se han tomado recientemente en por parte
de Estados Unidos Pero tiene que haber
medidas tomadas responsablemente desde
la región para evitar insisto los
procesos de remigración de migración
irregular y de remigración irregular el
Lamentablemente insisto terminan
fortaleciendo ellas a las redes de
tráfico y trata de personas por lo cual
es convocante insisto disminuir las
acciones de Estos espacios dominados por
algunas redes para estatales para que el
estado tome el control insisto en
materia de seguridad y sobre todo de
protección de Derechos Humanos Nancy
Rodrigo Muchas gracias por habernos
hecho este overview este panorama de la
situación de la migración en América
Latina de haber analizado para nosotros
y habernos explicado en más detalle la
situación que se está viviendo allí en
la frontera común entre Perú y chile
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros a ustedes Muchas gracias por la
sintonía y En nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos haber estado con
nosotros la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Andrés doncell y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera Pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]